I imagine that they're just like in
turtlenecks it's so you're thinking of
the priest collar like Irish people they
are always in turtlenecks I know with
Montoya font choice I'm cringing a
little bit right now
oh just push the person in a wheelchair
down here all right
sweaters paralyzed and sweater man they
really laughed at that we saw what's
left
I like that blanket that's really cute
Jesus blanket I want that for my house I
scream like that for brandy - I don't
think it's funny at all so hard am I am
I gonna offend a lot of people but I
like fur he does not take no for an
answer
the priests have bosses God and I'm
really liking father Jack I like I like
Google I like his his facing this I just
want to get the school in business
opened on what's filling I know anyway
perfect
what fellow this is this is very serious
don't make a balls of it right Wow stop
make a ball of it don't talk to me like
you're big - oh you fat piece of shite
what would it What did he say - yeah oh
my god this is this just got real yeah
stick this up your ass those Irish have
a dry sense of humor I'm definitely
attracted to him I'm attracted to him
yeah
I mean there's not many options in there
are any of them I mean this couples
great she's really sassy and she was
just about to shank this guy dog with
the socket on with her sort of thing we
should maybe we should just introduce
this until like American culture careful
father Ted careful now
there you got it
hang on yo per her I'm gonna start
saying I am me too I like it
thank you you want it back you [ __ ]
eejit am i doing it affecting me Jay I
feel like this is ahead of its time for
comedy
it's a little dated for me I want to
give another episode of shot though and
see what it's all about
I'm hooked oh yeah I'm not I want to
know what happened to say I feel I could
be a lot of rap songs like '[ __ ] you are
dick gray right there you got that
recorder right that's going platinum